nos dicen en este problema el círculo
con centro en p se muestra abajo y aquí
tenemos la imagen de nuestro círculo con
centro en p dice cuál es la medida del
arco veces en grados muy bien entonces
aquí podemos observar el punto b aquí
podemos observar el punto ce y dado que
sólo nos dieron dos letras verdad aquí
estamos calculando la medida del arco
veces son dos letras
entonces se está refiriendo al arco
menor es decir al arco más corto entre b
y c verdad entonces si quisiéramos
especificar el arco mayor tendríamos que
mencionar un punto intermedio verdad
podríamos decir por ejemplo el arco d
o el arco obedece muy bien pero aquí en
este caso nos está pidiendo el arco
menor verdad entonces voy a marcarlo
aquí este es el arco bs este es el arco
de c y este es del cual hay que obtener
su medida verdad entonces nosotros
sabemos que la medida de este arco es
exactamente igual por definición a la
medida del ángulo central que lo define
verdad entonces en la medida del arco bc
será igual a 4 k más 159° verdad
entonces para poder determinar quién es
quién es la medida de este arco bc
necesitamos saber cuánto vale acá verdad
entonces lo que podemos hacer aquí es
notar que el ángulo cpp es exactamente
igual al ángulo ap/the y eso es porque
estos dos ángulos estos dos ángulos son
opuestos por el vértice entonces tienen
exactamente la misma medida verdad
entonces podemos utilizar esa
información para encontrar la solución
tendremos que este ángulo que es 4 k más
159 tiene que ser exactamente igual a 2
k
153 verdad entonces lo único que tenemos
que hacer aquí es lograr despejar la
letra k para poder resolver el problema
así que digamos vamos a restar 2 k 2 k
de ambos lados y que es lo que obtenemos
bueno de este lado se cancelan aquí
verdad aquí obtendremos 2 acá más 159
será igual a 153 y ahora lo que podemos
hacer es restar 159 de ambos lados así
que restamos 159 de ambos lados del lado
izquierdo tendremos 2 acá y aquí
tendremos 153 menos 159 cuánto es 153
259 esto es menos 6 ahora dividimos
entre 2 de ambos lados verdad del lado
izquierdo simplemente nos queda acá y
del lado derecho nos queda menos 3 ok
tenemos que acá es igual a menos 3 y
aquí no hay razón para asustarse verdad
porque en realidad no es que el ángulo
sea menos 3 que no tendría sentido
verdad en realidad aquí obtenemos que
acá es menos 3 pero no es lo que
estábamos buscando nosotros buscábamos
el ángulo cpp y el ángulo ctv es 4 acá
más 159 verdad nosotros busco buscamos
este ángulo verdad así que para
calcularlo simplemente hay que sustituir
el valor de acá tendremos 4 x menos 3 +
159 es el valor de este ángulo 4 x menos
3 es menos 12 y luego hay que sumarle a
menos 12 159 es verdad o 159 menos 12
nos da exactamente
147 verdad entonces tú de hecho puedes
verificar que este ángulo 147 grados es
igual a 2 por cama 153 si sustituimos
cada igual a menos 3 verdad sería 2 x
menos 3 +153 puedes ver que también es
147 así que la solución a nuestro
problema es 147 grados vamos a hacer
otro otro ejercicio vamos a hacer uno
más
aquí tenemos otro ejercicio dice
nuevamente el círculo con centro en p se
muestra bajo cuál es la medida del arco
veces en grados y por supuesto otra vez
no nos dan más que un dos letras verdad
eso significa que nos referimos al arco
menor verdad entonces vamos a marcar
este arco menor
aquí tenemos el arco menor y como
siempre la medida de este arco del arco
bc es igual a la medida del ángulo
central que lo define verdad entonces en
este caso el el arco central se calcula
como la suma de estos dos verdad como 4g
más 6 y luego sumamos 7 y menos 7 así
que vamos a calcular esto tendremos
cuatro y más 6
7 y 7 entonces qué es lo que podemos
hacer vamos a sumar las 10 digamos
tenemos cuatro y más siete y esto nos da
11 ya y luego tenemos seis menos siete
entonces esto nos da menos 1 así que
este ángulo central que define al arco
bc vale exactamente 11 y menos 1 muy
bien entonces como podríamos descubrir
el valor de para poder calcular 11 y
menos uno que es el ángulo que nos
interesa bueno podemos utilizar la
información de este otro ángulo verdad
ya que la suma de estos dos ángulos este
ángulo rosa y este ángulo azul debe ser
exactamente 360 grados verdad porque ya
le dimos toda la vuelta pero el ángulo
azul nos dan la información vale 20 y
menos 11 entonces si nosotros sumamos 20
y menos 11 nos debe dar es
nos debe dar 360 grados verdad 360
grados entonces lo único que tenemos que
hacer aquí es lograr despejar la letra
de verdad entonces aquí tendremos por
ejemplo vamos a hacerlo con otro color
tendremos 11 y más 20 y nos da 31 de
verdad entonces tendremos 31 y luego
tenemos menos 1 menos 11 nos da menos 12
y esto es igual a 360 verdad así que
vamos a sumar 12 de ambos lados sumamos
12 de ambos lados del lado izquierdo se
cancelan y del lado derecho que es lo
que obtenemos aquí obtenemos 372 372 y
del lado izquierdo nos queda 31 de
verdad y ahora dividimos de ambos lados
entre 31 verdad
del lado izquierdo sólo nos queda ya y
del lado derecho veamos 372 entre 31 es
es exactamente 12 verdades todo esto
será 300 será 12 muy bien entonces
tenemos que ya es igual a 12 pero
recuerda en realidad nosotros no
estábamos buscando el valor de verdad no
era lo que nos interesaba nosotros
queríamos encontrar 11 menos uno que es
la medida de este ángulo y que por lo
tanto nos define la medida del arco bc
verdad entonces lo único que tenemos que
hacer es sustituir con ye igual a 12 así
que tendremos 11 por 12 que es nuestro
valor de y menos uno y esto veamos que
nos da 11 por 12 son 132 son 132 y si le
restamos 1 nos da 131 grados verdad
porque estamos hablando de la medida de
un ángulo entonces la medida de este
ángulo
verdad es 131 grados y eso será igual a
la medida del arco de ce